jean marc bonjour alors tout d'abord
comment expliquez vous ces difficultés à
repartir de l'activité économique
oui alors vous le disiez l'insee prévoit
effectivement un recul de l'activité de
9% sur l'année 2020 alors c'est
évidemment une catastrophe à l'échelle
des vingt dernières années il faut le
savoir qu'il ya encore quinze jours
la prévision était encore plus noir
d'ailleurs elle était de 11,9 pour cent
mettait la france au dernier rang de la
classe des pays européens avec les
anglais les espagnols
non là avec 9 % on va être dans la
moyenne européenne mais ça n'est on a
aucune raison de se réjouir de cette
situation
en fait beaucoup d'économistes penser
que les situations seraient repartis
beaucoup plus vite
après le confinement on aurait pu
rebondir un peu comme des balles vous
savez parce que rien n'avait été
détruire un peu comme un malade qu'on
plonge dans le coma pour l'opérer à la
fin ils se relaient depuis il galope
bien l'économie
elle a galopé un peu pendant pendant
deux mois mais mais mais après elle
s'est un peu c'est un peu renault par
est endormi mais mais s'est un peu
ralentie en fait on avait des espoirs
parce que rien n'avait été détruit les
bureaux les usines les machines les
camions pouvait redémarrer c'est pas
comme si on avait connu une guerre avec
des destructions non j'ajoute en plus
que les contrats de travail avaient été
préservés grâce au chômage partiel
enfin les consommateurs n'avaient pas
fait du shopping donc ils avaient des
économises n'est pas l'argent beaucoup
d'argent
le logiciel de la reprise pouvait
repartir alors dans les mois qui ont
suivi de déconfinement je vous disais en
mai juin bah ça a marché assez fort
d'ailleurs et puis en juillet en août
bah tout c'est assez actuellement c'est
mou alors il ya des secteurs qui sont
encore à l'arrêt je pense à l'hôtellerie
par exemple d'une hôtellerie des grandes
villes parce qu'elle vit principalement
avec la clientèle étrangère et la
clientèle étrangère
elle ne visitent toujours pas pour le
reste ça ça devrait tourner si je prends
une image on dirait un peu qu on est
comme des sportifs on a été dopée on a
été boosté avec de l'argent public
d'ailleurs
et puis maintenant on est on est
paralysée donc les entreprises hésitent
à investir les consommateurs ne consomme
pas alors qu'ils ont les moyens et une
économie sans client mais elle peut pas
fonctionner justement comment expliquez
vous cela
le manque de confiance le manque de
sciences cas liés à deux facteurs la
situation sanitaire
elle est anxiogène parce qu'elle
s'aggrave le virus n'a pas disparu au
contraire il se réveille il fait planer
des menaces sourde et lourdes sur le
système et puis vous avez la situation
économique derrière avec des risques de
chômage même si ces risques de chômage
notamment de voir une vague de millions
de chômeurs paraît improbable ça va être
sans doute plus modérée mais beaucoup
mais il faut qu'on trouve de la
croissance il faut qu'on tourne de la
croissance donc pour trouver de la
croissance il faut débloquer cet ehpad
qui actuellement ne sert à rien qui est
qui est scotché dans les comptes des
pannes sur les comptes bancaires
l'insee espère un choc de la demande
vers la fin de l'année le dernier
trimestre octobre décembre
ça va être décisif une choc d'un chef de
la demande pour une libération de tout
cet ehpad dans des conditions dans ces
conditions on retrouverait de la
croissance pour 2021
ces scénarios le maire bruno le maire
est selon vous comment combler ce manque
de confiance
ça c'est le métier des politiques c'est
le métier des politiques c'est le métier
d'éditeur
on a un exécutif qui financièrement a
fait le job infos font reconnaître plan
de soutien un plan de relance il s'est
beaucoup endetté il a beaucoup utilisé
de l'argent public certes mais si ça
marche on aura de la croissance donc on
aura de quoi payer la tête
donc de ce côté là il n'y a pas trop
d'inquiétudes au niveau technique mais
le gouvernement a quand même on le voit
bien un gros défaut il inspire pas
confiance et ça depuis le début de la
crise
1 dans son organisation dans ses
décisions d'ordre dans sa communication
aussi donc tout ça entretient la peur
est la peur ça piège l'économie
l'économie vous savez elle a besoin de
visibilité de stabilité et de certitudes
aucun de ces trois ingrédients
aujourd'hui n'est parfaitement réunies
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
d'avoir répondu à nos questions